some Diablo 4 beta players are
reportedly experiencing an issue that's
causing their gpus to overheat and break
the Early Access beta for the game ran
from March 17th through the 19th for
those who have pre-ordered the game and
it even extended part way through March
20th allowing for several more hours of
play however during this period some
players came across a problem that would
cause their PC to shut down one player
Jonesy 23 told Eurogamer quote I wanted
to wrap up my play time with the beta on
Monday played for about 20 minutes then
my PC shut down unexpectedly my GPU was
so hot that it burned my fingers when
touching the HDMI connector luckily it
was not permanently damaged I thought
it's an isolated instance but I found
some articles saying that more people
experienced it and they were not as
lucky as I was more players took to the
Diablo 4 forums to report similar issues
and blizzard responded by confirming
it's currently aware of this problem and
offered players some temporary advice
eyes on how to avoid an overheated GPU
the developer said quote the team is
working closely with Nvidia to identify
affected Hardware configurations and
gather as many data points as possible
to assist in the investigation blizzard
then shared some instructions to help
players which consisted of turning the
PC off and on and seeing if the GPU can
be detected under Windows if it can be
found do a clean driver install in some
lighter news depending on who you are
blizzard has confirmed the open Beta
features higher than normal drop rates
the news comes via Diablo general
manager Rod Ferguson on Twitter who
responded to a fan question about the
drop rate Ferguson confirmed that the
drop rates are increased in the beta for
testing purposes Ferguson's answers
still leaves some room for confusion
however most players seem to assume
Ferguson was specifically talking about
legendary item drops but his tweet could
simply refer to all item drops in
general numerous players responded to
Ferguson's tweet with relief in regards
to the news but others are now concerned
that the drop rates for non-legendary
items in the full version of the game
might be too low some fans have taken
issue with the fact that the drop rate
is different in the beta than it will be
in the full game and are now worried
what the experience will be like at
launch on June 6th players have been
curious about the drop rate since the
start of the game's Early Access beta
period when numerous Diablo content
creators and others on places like the
Diablo subreddit remarked on how drop
rates seemed incredibly High many
players were easily able to deck out
their characters in legendary gear
before reaching the beta's level cap of
25 despite only playing on the game's a
second world tier difficulty beating the
beta's only World boss awarded a high
number of legendaries in particular with
players reportedly earning up to eight
or nine legendary items for slaying the
Beast for the first time feedback
regarding item drop rates hasn't been
the only concern fans have had while
playing the Diablo 4 beta many perceive
the game's Barbarian class to be far
weaker than Alternatives like the Rogue
and Sorcerer And blizzard agrees Buffs
will be coming to the Barbarian in the
full version of the game as a result are
you planning on playing Diablo 4 this
weekend leave a comment letting me know
how long you waited in a queue and we'll
see you next week
foreign